[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: This is
how enterprise teams
can succeed using Firebase.
And for those of you
who don't know who I am,
which is probably like
one or two of you max,
my name is [? Abe ?] Haskins.
I say I'm a software engineer,
but I'm actually not.
I work in developer relations
at Google working on Firebase.
I've been working on Firebase
in one way or the other
for about six years, which is
about six of the seven years
Firebase has existed
as a product.
So I have been helping people--
big companies, small companies,
hobbyists, kids in school,
et cetera, et cetera--
use Firebase for a long time.
And this is going to be
the trend in this talk,
is that I do not care--
I genuinely do not care if you
go and leave today and think,
I need to use Firebase
for something.
It's going to make
me super successful.
Like, that's great if
you do leave with that.
But I have no interest at all
in you going and using Firebase
only to figure out that
it doesn't work well
with your product, it's
not a good investment,
you misplaced engineering
time or anything like that.
My goal here is to
help you be informed.
And if Firebase is the
right thing for you,
I'd love for you to go use it.
But I've been doing this long
enough that I know telling you
anything but the
absolute truth is not
going to do you any good.
So that's what I'm going to do.
I am honest when I say I
have no interest in selling
you anything.
I just hope you can leave today
with a little more information
about Firebase and a little
bit of a better idea about what
it takes to run Firebase in a
big team with a big product,
and to succeed doing that.
I think the thing that
is the core of all
of this when you're
building anything large
is, you've got to be confident.
All right?
You have to be confident
in a bunch of factors.
And if you're a
small company you
have to be confident
in things like,
being able to pay
the rent next month.
But as you grow and you get
revenue and things like this,
your concerns
change and you have
to be focused about scaling--
confident about
scaling the team,
or you need to be confident
about being able to roll back
something when it gets
pushed into production
and it has some issue.
But the general theme, building
confidently, always applies.
It doesn't matter who you are.
In my experience,
the idea of building
confidently kind of breaks down
into a few core components.
And these are what we're going
to be talking about today--
and specifically
talking about how
to use these things
as we scale up,
as we deploy into
bigger teams and we
get past that small
company building
on Firebase kind of thing.
So those topics are how to
build clean and strong code.
A lot of these topics will be
engineering-related, but not
specifically about writing code.
They're more about managing
code, managing projects,
how to deal with teams and
adding developers and things
like that.
Then we'll be dealing with the
idea of systematic testing.
And again, you might
think, all right, testing.
We have quality
assurance people.
We have our developers
write tests.
But this is more about, like,
as an organization, as a team,
as several teams working on
microservices or whatever.
What do we do to ensure
that testing is consistent,
systematic and as useful as
it can be without putting
too much burden on anyone.
Then we're going to
talk about dealing
with instant deployments
and roll back,
how we can react to things
when inevitably our tests don't
catch something, we push
something bad into production.
We won't dive too
deep into that.
It'll just kind of be
a high-level overview,
but it's still a
really useful topic.
After that we'll
talk about something
that a lot of enterprises
care about with Firebase,
which is dealing with
multiple environments.
We want to have staging
environments and production
environments.
We want to have
different services
that our products
connect to, depending
on what environment they're in.
We want this or that.
And we'll talk about how that
works in a Firebase world.
Then we'll talk about
monitoring and kind of dive
into how do we get
confidence in what's
happening in our application?
Any time you trust a cloud
provider, as you know--
like, right there that
word "trust" comes up.
You have to have confidence
that we are doing
the right thing on your behalf.
And so we'll talk about how
you can keep an eye on us,
ensure that what we're doing on
your behalf is what you want.
This is things like uptime and
on-call rotations and ideas
like that.
Then after that we'll
talk a bit about pricing.
I'm far from a pricing
guru, but I can give you
some hints about how to think
about pricing as it relates
to Firebase, how to do some sort
of forward-looking analysis.
Just a little bit on that.
And just some of the value props
that change when you're looking
at using something like
Firebase versus a more
closer-to-bare-metal stack
like Google Cloud or even
a fully-traditional
on-prem solution.
So that's what we're
going to go over.
We're going to just step
through those one at a time,
so we're just going to dive
into the first one, which
is clean, strong code.
Now, if you are an existing
company using Firebase,
there's a couple of situations
you might find yourself in.
And generally
enterprise developers
find themselves in
one specific one,
which is that you
have some product
and that product makes a lot
of money for your company,
probably, hopefully.
And you have some
other part that
is the part that uses Firebase.
This happens for
a lot of reasons,
but the biggest ones are that
Firebase is a great value add.
So if you're a new team building
up something inside of a bigger
company, it lets you move fast.
It lets you do things
really quickly.
You can kind of get a minimum
viable thing out, and then
iterate on it.
And we see a lot of products
like that using Firebase.
And then the other type of
enterprise using Firebase
is any enterprise that's
actually relying on Firebase
as a core part of its business.
This is extremely rare.
And this is one of
the reasons that it's
important Firebase is as
connected to Google Cloud
as it is today.
We want to make sure that as
you grow and build with Firebase
there is a clear connection
between Firebase and Google
Cloud.
So if you're using Google
Cloud or you're using Firebase
and you realize you need
something from the other one,
they're not mutually exclusive.
They're designed
to work together
and to kind of help each other.
But in either of
these cases, if you're
using Firebase
somewhere in your stack,
you've probably realized
that the code you're writing
is a little sloppy.
This happens all the time.
It's just kind of part
of building things today.
And I would argue
that it's not just
a side-effect of writing code.
I think there's a
specific culture
that working with
Firebase lends itself to,
which is the culture building
quickly and iterating
on things, that also lends
itself to writing bad code.
And that's what I
call the MVP culture,
or that Minimum Viable
Product culture.
And this is a bit of a tangent.
I'll give you that.
But I think it's a
really interesting one
to think about--
where, if you're
building an MVP inside
of your enterprise, which
is, as I said, what a lot
of Firebase developers do,
then you have to wonder what
is changing about this product
as I'm building it.
Right?
You're like, all right, these
features are going to change.
I'm going to figure out what
users want and respond to that.
But in that churn what
happens to the code?
Right?
The code gets mangled.
You're like, oh, there
was this whole other thing
we built we don't need,
and then we drop that off.
We don't do anything with it.
We built up this other part.
Maybe the entire original
purpose of the code base
gets shifted.
All sorts of crazy
things happen.
And that's fine, because
when we're building an MVP
we're writing the
minimum amount of code.
We're doing so in
a way that allows
us to, because the
iteration time is faster.
We're not spending
a ton of time,
like, declaring a SOAP API
or something crazy like that.
We're just like, eh,
throw up some JavaScript.
Throw up a serverless
function that can do this.
And-- there's a mouse.
Pretend that didn't happen.
And all of these
things are fine.
But the result in
this-- the end result
is not just a better product
at the end of the day,
but it's actually
pretty expensive
because you're iterating on
this code base very quickly.
You're changing things.
And as you do that, you're going
to allow your developers more
time to go back and
rewrite the same thing
and rewrite the same
thing, and you build up
a lot of code debt this way.
You build up a lot
of issues that you're
going to have to deal
with down the road.
And this is part
of this MVP culture
that people don't
really talk about.
And I see this particularly in
enterprises trying to spin up
things quickly in Firebase.
Because you're always
under crazy constraints,
and you always have something
that has to be done next week.
And they build like this.
So when we talk
about MVPs, when we
talk about this idea
of iterating quickly,
there is one friendly
language that always comes up.
It is this one.
It's JavaScript.
If you have ever written
anything with Firebase,
you've probably touched
JavaScript at some point,
whether it's using one
of our JavaScript SDKs
or using the Cloud Functions,
which most people write
in JavaScript.
But despite the
better iteration time,
despite JavaScript's ability to
allow you to write code really
fast and spin stuff up and
really quickly get something
together, it has a
ton of downsides.
And some of you may
be thinking, of course
I know JavaScript is not
the perfect language,
but I really want to
stress this as it relates
to Firebase because a
huge number of developers
don't understand that if
you're using something
like Cloud Functions
for Firebase
or any of our other services,
you are definitely not
locked into JavaScript.
JavaScript makes sense
in some situations,
but in others it doesn't.
And so here's an example,
a snippet of JavaScript.
This is some code that
interacts with Firebase.
It's just, like, a call to the
database, checks if a user has
an admin role, returns a value.
And if you are a really keen
JavaScript developer or even
a pretty keen
JavaScript developer,
you might realize that this
snippet makes no sense.
All right?
But if you are anything but
a pretty keen JavaScript
developer, this
probably looked fine.
And this is exactly the issue
with JavaScript as it grows
and as you work
with bigger teams
and grow your product
and things like that.
A good developer-- a real good
developer can see the problem
here, but an average
developer can't.
A new developer can't.
A developer who is not familiar
with Firebase or these SDKs
can't.
All right?
So here's the cheat sheet
of what's wrong with this.
Obviously firebase.database
is a function,
so you're missing
your invocation there.
How could you not notice that?
We're missing a return.
This value never actually
gets out anywhere.
We don't have a callback.
We don't return the promise.
And, of course,
that string, val,
is actually supposed
to be value.
All these are trivial.
Right?
They're a couple of characters.
They're an easy
mistake to make, even
if you're familiar
with JavaScript,
with the Firebase SDK.
But if you are not
that person, if you
are anyone else
coming into this team,
you're probably
going to miss this.
So this leads me
to a general idea
I have about choosing
languages and choosing
what to build your
product in and what
to build with in
Firebase, which is
that the language
your code is in
should be as strict as
the contracts provided
by the services
it interacts with.
This is kind of a weird mantra.
And it basically is saying,
don't use JavaScript.
It's probably the wrong idea.
It's a little more
formal than that so you
can tell it to people and
they think you're smart.
But let me explain
what I mean here.
So imagine you have a big
micros service architecture.
Maybe it's a serverless
architecture.
You got a bunch of
functions around.
That's great.
Right?
You have some off-service
that a bunch of other services
rely on.
You have ordering and scheduling
and tracking and reporting.
And that core service
provides an API
that all of these
services relate to.
In reality, there's
a chance at first
that the ordering and the
scheduling and the tracking
and the reporting
and the auth are all
maintained by the same
team, but once you
grow, once you get a
few auth providers,
once you get a bigger
and bigger team,
you're going to get a bunch
of these that are all now
providing different APIs,
that all of these services
are now expected to know
how to interact with.
And this interaction
here, that JSON bit,
is a very loose, very,
very soft format.
You can send back
anything you want,
and the other service is
expected to handle it.
So if, for example, our social
auth, our Facebook auth,
and our Twitter auth hands back
an object to these services.
That looks one way.
Maybe it has display
underscore name.
But our internal auth-- that
hands back something else.
That hands back something
that's called display Name,
with a capital "N", camel case.
So we get into this issue
where now these core services
are providing different
APIs, different services,
to all these dependents.
And now each of
these dependents is
responsible for handling
the different cases,
the different situations
that could be provided
by this very loose API.
And in this case
JavaScript might
make sense, because if
all of these services
are providing
different things, you
don't have a strong contract
between your different
services, between your service
functions and your client side.
If you don't have
that guarantee,
you want a very
flexible language.
You want a language
like JavaScript
that can take
whatever you give it
and probably mangle it
into something usable.
But we don't want to get in this
situation in the first place,
because this doesn't scale.
Right?
Like, as soon as you start doing
this a bunch and you have not
only an auth service
or a few auth services,
maintained perhaps
by different people--
at least some were maintained
by people from three years ago,
some are working there
now, some don't know--
you're going to hit this issue.
So we have this snippet
with a bunch of issues.
Right?
And of course we're
thinking, well, we
aren't talking about JSON here.
We're not talking
about any interaction
here that is nice and
soft and loose like JSON.
We have a really
strong contract here.
We have an SDK.
We have a nice, nice
documented, clean, consistent,
properly-typed, beautiful SDK--
Firebase SDK here, and we're
just throwing that all away.
And we're just like, we don't
care that this does not--
this might be able to tell me
that database is a function.
We don't care that it knows
it's supposed to take value.
We just toss this out.
And this is kind of
the core realization
here that I'd like
you to take away
from this bit, which is that
these SDKs that we provide,
that Google Cloud provides,
that Firebase provides--
these are contracts that
we are making to you.
Obviously not legal contracts.
Not something that you
can sue us if we change.
But they are the
type of thing that we
do our absolute best not to
mess with you and not to change.
So in this situation where we
have all of this information,
throwing it away,
using it in JavaScript
makes a lot less sense.
So this SDK is a
strong contract.
Right?
We're communicating
between these services--
in this case Firebase
services, but in this example
it's an internal app
communicating to a dependent.
Strongly-typed languages
make more sense.
Because there is
nothing loose here.
There is nothing flexible
about this contract
from another service.
So if we look at this snippet
again we think, all right.
Why are we relying
on a language that
lets us have that flexibility?
It really doesn't
gain us that much.
In fact, it makes
the situation worse
because now developers
are making mistakes.
They have to iterate more.
They have to come back and,
as things change, which
they inevitably will, they are
more likely to break this code.
So here's the same
function rewritten
into a typed language.
It looks almost
identical, doesn't it?
I mean, yeah.
It's pretty much-- it's
slightly different.
It honestly just looks like
more modern JavaScript.
But introducing some
TypeScript into the situation
changes the world for us.
This is now a valid
TypeScript snippet.
And although we haven't
put any types on here--
we don't say uid is a string, we
don't promise that we're going
to return a value or
anything like that--
we are making use of the
contract provided by Firebase.
Because if we tried to
compile this and turn it
into JavaScript and we had any
of those mistakes back here--
excuse me.
If we had any of the
mistakes back here,
TypeScript would tell us.
Right?
So we're making a
very small change--
like, a few characters.
But now the end result
is that our code
is making use of that contract.
It's saying, I know you're
giving me this data,
you're giving me these
fields and these objects
and these things like that.
Well, let's actually
listen and obey those.
So just this switch to
TypeScript-- very low cost
in general, especially
for new projects.
If you're building
something up old
and you're trying
to transition it,
it can be pretty
expensive to shift.
But if you're building
something new,
you're trying to
MVP something, this
will save you time-- just
switching to TypeScript.
I love TypeScript,
but my whole talk
is not just about TypeScript.
But one last part that is about
TypeScript is code completion.
I don't know if you've ever
used JavaScript code completion
or if you've ever seen a
new developer on your team
try to figure out what
the hell is going on
in your JavaScript--
but they're not
going to get
anything this pretty.
They're not going to
get anything that says,
here are the methods that
are actually on this SDK.
They're going to get
a whole bunch of junk
that, like, Sublime thinks
it can read and realize,
because it's got some
crazy regx and it's like,
this is probably a JavaScript
value, but it's not good.
It's not helpful.
And, frankly, it
can be misleading.
So if we use a stronger type
language, not only have we
now enabled our systems to use
and consume those contracts,
but we're improving
the experience
for these new developers.
They're coming in and
they're seeing this
and they're saying, all right.
I can figure this out.
I can reason about this better.
I can get up to speed quicker,
and I can make changes more
confidently.
So one last bit about this
whole service contract language
decision is that I
want to point out
that services are anything
a team relies on which isn't
written by that same team.
So when I say
"services," I don't just
mean things like Google Cloud.
I don't mean things
like Firebase.
It can be, like the earlier
example, your auth service.
There is no reason your auth
service couldn't provide
an SDK with that really
nice, strict contract
that they maintain and they
give to the other teams and say,
you don't have to talk
over our JSON API.
If that API changes,
we'll take care of it.
But we maintain both the core
service and the associated SDK,
which is what you actually
use to talk to our service.
And now if they make
a change in their SDK
because they made a change
on their server code,
you can now respond
to that reasonably.
Can get build time errors.
You can get more
information than you
would if that SDK
or that situation
was more loosely-typed.
The other thing that
counts as a service is,
every single one of those node
modules you've ever pulled in--
for example, if I
went and I tried
to find a colors module to just
throw some color in my logging
output--
I don't know if you know
this, but there's 3,600 color
modules, which is ridiculous.
A lot of them are
not what I want,
but if I didn't know what I want
I'd be able to kind of reduce
it down to two these two.
And when I go and I
take on a dependency
from a third party like
this, I'm making an agreement
with that person
that's saying, I'm
trusting you on a
bunch of levels.
I'm trusting you not to do
anything evil in my code,
because once I'm
importing your JavaScript
you can do whatever
the heck you want.
You can break my page.
You can steal my information.
So you have that level
of contract and agreement
with them.
But you're also making a
technical agreement saying,
please don't change this
API too much, because if you
do I'm not going to know.
Like, it's just going to break
in production at some point
if they change how
these APIs work.
And some developers are much
more reasonable and much more
considerate, and
they're willing to make
a guarantee of some form
with you that their API is
going to be a certain way.
And we can look at
these two packages.
If we were to look at these
without being a JavaScript
developer, or being a
new JavaScript developer
or what have you, it would
be impossible to tell
which of these is
the ideal one to use.
You might know
offhand, but we can go
and we can look into these
repos and we can check out
the package.json
file for colors,
and you'll notice
through all this
there is no mentions of
types or any guarantee
that what we're outputting
here is going to stay the same.
And this is the
non-TypeScript library.
It's usable, but
it's also deprecated.
It's several years old, and
it's definitely not the choice
you want to make.
This one, "chalk,"
on the other hand--
you can see right
there under "files"
there's a type/index.d.ts.
And that's saying, hey,
here's the actual file
that defines the contract
I'm providing you
what your service can rely on.
So if this changes, if that DTS
file changes on a new release,
that'll be a build time error
instead of a runtime error.
And that's a better sign of
a developer willing to make
a commitment to you,
upholding some bar of quality,
than the ones who don't.
So this is a yay TypeScript
kind of situation.
And I generally recommend, even
if you're not using TypeScript,
look for libraries
that support TypeScript
because it's a better indicator
that people are willing to be
consistent and they're not just
changing things willy-nilly
under you.
This doesn't help at all if this
person is malicious, obviously.
They can still steal
all your information.
But at least your code's
not going to change.
So with all these thousands
of trust relationships
we have with external
people, ideally
they would all be contracts.
Right?
Like, every single one
of these we would say,
you were providing
me this type of SDK.
You were providing me
this cloud service,
this whatever, whatever.
And you would have this very,
very nice, clean structure.
But there are certain
languages which just don't lend
themselves well to doing this.
JavaScript is one of those.
So if the language is
weak, because that's
the contract between the
provider and the dependent,
your entire service
is going to be weak.
If your language is strong,
it's going to be stronger.
So any strictly-typed language--
Go, for example,
Java, for example--
are great choices here.
And luckily you
might be thinking,
well, this is all great, but
Firebase, Cloud Functions--
they only support JavaScript.
Maybe they support TypeScript,
but it's not really that--
which is not true.
You can write Go code and deploy
it up to Cloud Functions today.
You can use all of the
same triggers you use.
You can use all the
same stuff, and it's
going to work just as well.
We have Go SDKs.
We have SDKs from many
strictly-typed languages
on the back-end.
We have a lot of choices
here that aren't JavaScript
that still allow you flexibility
and speed of development,
but with nice, strict contracts
that we're agreeing to,
to make sure that what
we give you is either
going to be the same
as it was before
or it's going to
fail at build time.
So that's my whole
spiel about languages.
Don't write in JavaScript.
Write in TypeScript.
Or even better yet, write in
Go or something like that.
But we got a lot else
to cover, and that
was a pretty long section.
So I want to talk about
systematic testing.
So the first thing
about testing,
if you're writing a
big team-- and this
goes back to that
MVP culture thing.
Right?
Like, MVPs generally don't
have tests, which is terrible.
But one of the
reasons they don't is
because testing is pretty hard.
It's a very difficult
thing to get right.
And if you're trying
to move quickly,
a lot of times "move fast
and break things" means
"break things because
we didn't write tests."
And we need to do what
we can, culturally,
when we're building things, to
avoid getting into situations
where it's hard to test things.
So here's an example, another
snippet, another Firebase code,
more JavaScript.
And it's, unlike the
other JavaScript,
a little more recent.
It's got some async/await.
It's got some other stuff.
The problem with this code
is that the only thing
this JavaScript
module is exporting
is this Cloud
Function definition.
So we can deploy
this to Firebase,
and once it's in
production at Firebase
we can hit it and see what
happens and we test it,
but that is incredibly slow.
It's like a minute at least
of loop for you to go,
I'm going to change
this, deploy it, test it.
And worse than that, you need
to be deploying it constantly
to our staging
environment, which you have
to have in the first place.
And it's very, very tedious.
So if we get into a situation
where instead of building out
this big method that
whatever it does it
sends messages or push
notifications to people,
we restructure it.
And we expose that same
business logic in multiple ways
that is now independent
of the vendor.
So this is code, and this
is an example of me saying,
don't do it the Firebase way if
you can because all the testing
tools, all the unit tools,
all the spies and everything
like that in the world, are
not going to make it easier
for you to test your
code than if you just
export a normal method
that you can just tie into
and check the result of.
So that's what we're doing here.
We're taking this
old big blob of code
and moving all this business
logic, all the part that you'd
actually want to
test, throwing it
into a new method, which
we call "send to room."
And then after that,
instead of just exposing
that one Cloud Function,
that one Firestore trigger,
we're going to expose a
couple different things.
We're going to expose
a manual trigger, which
is an HTTPS function.
This we can emulate
locally, so it's very easy
to hit and get a
response from, and see
if send to room with data
is working as we'd expect.
We now have the
automatic room, which
is an automatic send
to room function.
This is exactly
like it was before.
And you can see any
logic that's related
to that Firestore trigger
is going to be tied
in in this little bit of code.
So we're pulling in
from text, roomId,
and passing that to send
to room, which is just
a normal JavaScript function.
So just by reorganizing
things a little bit
and always having a manual
way to trigger things,
we're helping avoid the
situation where a developer is
going to go and have to
deploy something to test it,
and increase that time to loop.
Here's everything we did
that makes this better.
We export a top-level
namespace now,
which you can do
with Cloud Functions.
You can import, like, an
infinitely-deep object
and it'll automatically
namespace things for you.
So when you deploy this you'll
get fcm underscore manual.
You'll get fcm
underscore automatic,
underscore dash send to room.
So we do that.
We have that HTTPS function.
We have function-specific
logic handled
all in the actual
trigger invocation,
and the business logic
pops somewhere else.
Now, this is great.
This is a helpful way
to organize your code,
but it's not as
good as just being
able to invoke this code as it
is, the full production code
naturally.
Which, I have some
good news for you.
I wish I could tell you
more, but we are working
on new Firebase emulators.
We're working on an entire
suite of new emulators
that will allow you to do
entirely offline development
without deploying
to Firebase at all.
So this will make a lot of
things moot in this talk,
actually, but we're not
we're not there yet.
But once we're
getting there, we're
going to have a much,
much better story for you
in terms of testing
and things like that.
So in the meantime, keep
listening to what I'm saying,
but keep a lookout
for the new emulators
that are coming down the pipe.
It's been far too
long that we have not
had a good offline story for
Firebase, and that is coming.
Beyond that, testing
can't be optional.
If anything is
remotely difficult
and you give someone
the option not to do it,
they probably won't do it.
So we've got to make sure
they test their code.
We can kind of make
sure they write tests.
Right?
Like, we can have
code reviews and we
can have things like that
that ensure coverage.
We can use tools like
coveralls to make sure
that a good percentage of
our code is covered by tests.
But we also have
all these tools.
This text is a
little small, but we
have a lot of ways
to automatically deal
with running tests that
enforce developers use tests
all the time.
For example, just to name a few,
you can use Git Commit Hooks.
So if somebody commits
code, it has to pass tests
or it has to have a certain
coveralls percentage.
We can do Automated Branch
Reviews from bots and things
like GitHub.
There's Hot-reloadable Tests,
which make it much more
approachable to rerun tests.
We have all sorts
of different things.
Team-provided Mocks.
This goes back to the idea that
if your service is providing
an SDK, that SDK
should also have mocks
provided by that same team.
We can have code hygiene
practices, CI/CD stuff,
we can have hooks in
the Firebase CLI--
all sorts of stuff that
enforce these tests be
ran by our developers.
So regardless of who
this developer is,
they're not getting code in
unless they run the tests.
And this is all just making
it part of the workflow.
Right?
We just want developers
to always be thinking,
I'm going to write
test for this.
Tests are my default
way of testing this.
I'm not going to click
through and click the buttons
and see if it works.
I'm going to write a
test, because that's
going to be better.
I want to talk specifically
a bit more about this, which
is leading into our next
section about deployments
and rollbacks.
Some of you have probably heard
about this really cool service
we have called Cloud Build.
And if you haven't
heard about Cloud Build,
you've probably heard about one
of our competitors' products.
There's tons of good
CI/CD options out here,
and this is one of
those situations where
I don't particularly care if
you use Cloud Build or you use
any of the other ones.
Use the one that's best for you.
Cloud Build is sweet because it
integrates with Google Cloud,
so if your code's
already in Google Cloud
and your life is
already in Google Cloud,
you might as well
use Cloud Build.
But there's a lot of
great options out there.
A lot of good documentation,
et cetera, et cetera.
To give you some idea about
what Cloud Build offers
in the simplest situation--
if you've never used CI/CD,
your team is still
either manually
moving files to a
server or your team
is relying on the one dude who
remembers how to deploy code.
Like, he's the one with
the right shell scripts.
This is for you.
If your team already has
CI/CD stuff, that's fine.
You can tune out for a second.
So Cloud Builder is
super approachable.
Continuous integration,
continuous deployment tool.
If you don't know
what that means,
that means when you commit to
Git or you hit some button,
it builds your code,
it tests your code,
and it ships your code either
to production and staging, what
have you.
It's a bit hard to see
in this tiny screenshot,
but the general idea here
is that every time I've
done anything to this code
base it runs these tests.
You see a bunch of them
are failing, because I
wrote a bunch of bad tests.
But that's fine.
It's only trying
to go to staging.
[LAUGHS] It's only
going to production.
It's only going to staging.
So if the build fails, it
doesn't matter if it succeeds.
Great.
I can go check it.
And this is kind
of the magic here,
is that all of the process
that you would normally
do to get something into any
environment is contained here.
And it's replicate-able
because all you have to do
is commit to Git or do whatever,
and that's a very easy way
to get something out.
The actual setup for
this is super trivial.
Again, this is probably a
bit hard to read, sadly,
but you just make one of these
wonderful Cloud Build YAML
files.
They can pull in any arbitrary
Docker file, and that can run.
So we have G Cloud,
CLI, Docker files.
We have Firebase
CLI Docker files.
We have all sorts of
node and any static site
builder you would want,
or anything like that.
You can just pull in as a step
in this, and then it'll go.
And every time you
commit it will go and run
this and deploy it up.
So here's an example
of a situation
where I've synced it to Git.
We have a bunch of options here.
You can use the Cloud
Source repositories, which
are the Git repos
inside of Google
Cloud that most people
don't know about
but are super helpful.
We also actually have an
editor built into Google Cloud.
If you've never used
that, check that out.
But if you're already on
GitHub, you're already
on it Bitbucket,
whatever-- you can also
use a bunch of other
places, I think.
That's fine.
You can just say, hey, anytime
I commit to GitHub hook this in,
run this code.
So in this case
I've been working
on whatever service this is.
It's clearly a very
good commit log.
I'm a very good developer.
And imagine that last
commit I made a mistake.
Right?
I have accidentally
broken something.
It's failing in production.
Somehow it got past my tests.
Somehow we got in
this situation.
So a deployment looks like this.
And if it goes, it goes past
those tests and it succeeds,
we'll see all the logs.
We'll see information about
what container it built.
We'll see all that nice output
of what this build resulted in.
And in this case the artifact
of this build is a container,
but it doesn't have to be.
You can just use it to deploy
things or whatever you want.
It absolutely does not
have to be a container.
But, like I said, if
I've made a mistake
and I have committed something
wrong or anyone on our team
has committed something wrong
and accidentally got something
into production, it's
pretty easy to roll back.
Right?
In a traditional situation
you pull down the Git repo.
Right?
You remember how to roll
back the latest commit, which
I have no idea how to do.
I would have to Google that
and be like, all right.
Something, something,
head hard reset something.
And after probably like 10
minutes of messing around
I'd be able to figure out
how to go back a commit,
and then I'd be able
to go rerun the scripts
and get into production.
But if you have a nice tool
like this, all of these builds
are really nice and contained.
So again, hard to
see, but there's
a very tiny button up at the
top that just says "rebuild."
And if I hit that rebuild
button, it's going to go.
It's going to go to the commit
that this build was built on,
rerun everything,
redo all the steps,
and at the end of the day
throw that build back up.
And by "the end of the
day" I mean after, like,
30 seconds once
it's done building.
So now, instead of panicking
and looking up Git logs
and remembering how to do
this, we can just say, oh.
OK.
Just roll back.
Just hit that button, and
we are now back that commit.
We turn a few
minutes of downtime
out of what could have been
half-hour or more of people
trying to remember
how to do things,
looking up obscure
documentation,
things like that.
So it's really, really helpful.
I think one of the
things that CI/CD tools
are most valuable for is not
just deploying to production,
because that's great.
But if we want people to
always be testing their code
and always experimenting
and things like that,
we really want to have
different environments.
And this leads into
the next topic here,
where you have configs
and environmental codes.
By "config" I mean things like
API keys, servers, anything
that your service is
actually talking to.
These are all
configuration values.
Right?
Any port, anything like that.
And then we have
environments, which
are kind of groups of
configuration information.
So if you have a service that's
talking to a MySQL database,
for example, and
you know that when
you deploy that
service to staging
and you have to tell it to talk
to a different MySQL database,
you have to run it with
the right config value.
You have to deploy it to staging
with the right config values.
Otherwise what's
going to happen is,
it's going to talk to
the production database
and very bad things
are going to happen.
You're either going
to leak PII or you're
going to accidentally
delete something
you didn't mean to delete,
or anything like that.
And this is why we
get into this idea--
and this is a very
Firebasey idea.
The Firebase knows where
your project is running.
At anytime any code you're
writing with Firebase
has an idea of what project
it's associated with.
So this is true in
our client-side SDKs.
So if you're running
in the Android SDK,
you can get that
project idea out
and you can say, all
right, what project ID
is my base configuration for?
If you're writing
a Cloud Function,
we have environmental
configuration values.
They're basically
environment variables,
but made a little nicer.
And these know exactly
what environment you're in.
So if I was building a
service and I was working out
these configuration
values I'm thinking,
here's my user's
database, and here's
my whatever-whatever database.
If I committed that
into Git, not only
do I not have a log of
potentially-sensitive
information, there could
be credentials in there
or anything like that, but
we're also into a situation
where it's up to the
developer-- again,
think of the new developer.
Think of someone who doesn't
have that much experience here.
It's up to them
to know to switch
those with the right credentials
when they deploy into staging.
So another mantra, Git is
for code, not configuration.
There are very few situations
where you should store
your configuration data in Git.
It generally doesn't
work well, because if you
leak a secret accidentally,
it's very hard to undo.
And if you have a situation
where these variables are
limited in scope,
you're now dealing
with specific permissions
to a Git repo and, like,
only this person
should be able to read,
and this person can change them.
It's much, much easier to keep
all of that configuration data
in the environment.
So let me give you two examples
of what that looks like.
Here is a web page--
a very simple web page
pulling in environmental
data from Firebase.
So if you've ever deployed a
web app on Firebase Hosting,
this is the gist
of what you can do.
And it looks basically the same.
We're pulling in the
two Firebase SDKs,
we're ready to use Firebase SDK.
That's great.
But we have that
bottom line there,
that underscore underscore
firebase.init.js.
And what that's doing is saying,
hey, initialize my Firebase app
on my JavaScript to
point to whatever project
I'm currently running on.
So if you're deploying
this locally,
it'll be whatever your
local project is set to use.
If you're deploying
this to production
it will automatically pull
it from the environment.
So this means you can now commit
this without any configuration
information.
You commit it to Git.
And then when you
go to deploy it,
it will automatically connect
to where you deploy it.
So now, if we're talking
about a staging environment
and a production
environment or a development
environment or whatever, we're
not concerned about this.
We can deploy the exact
same code, no changes,
and it'll be safe.
Diving into this a little more,
here's another Cloud Function,
some more lovely JavaScript
that I don't recommend using.
And you can see here, we do
some simple onWrite for checking
email, send some
service to that.
But we have this authorization
token down there.
If you're not familiar
with that syntax,
that's just string interpolation
in modern JavaScript.
The important part
is, functions.config
.someservice.key.
That's a key stored in
our environment that
isn't checked into our code.
It's not written down anywhere
except in Google Cloud
where it's nice and safe.
So when you go to
call this service,
there's no chance you're
going to call the production
credentials.
The thing I always think
about here is Stripe.
If you're ever doing
Stripe payment processing,
the likelihood that
you will use your test
key in your production
environment or vice versa
is very high.
So doing this
allows you to really
easily separate that and just
be like, my code is my code.
My configuration is
in the environment,
and I have my two or
three projects set up
that are the ones we
deploy to and test with.
And unless we allow someone
to accidentally deploy it
to production, there's no
way they're accidentally
charging on Stripe or
doing something like that.
So, yeah.
If your code has no
configuration and no idea
about the environment, or
it has no context of what
project to associate
with, it has
no idea what's going on except
from what the environment tells
us.
You write these really nice,
clean, independent bundles
of code.
It's a much easier,
much more [INAUDIBLE]
bundle that you can then take
and deploy to different places
and ship round.
It's extremely, extremely clean.
But this isn't everything.
Right?
We've been talking a
lot about writing code,
and we don't have that
much time so luckily
we're getting into
the last few sections.
That once your code
is in the real world,
you want to keep an eye on it.
And any time we're
talking about keeping
an eye on anything
in Google Cloud,
we're talking about Stackdriver.
You've probably used
Stackdriver or heard of it.
It's an incredibly powerful
tool for just all sorts
of analysis of your code
and your performance
and all of these great things.
It has all these metrics
of Google services.
Firebase is no exception.
Throws off to it.
If you ever wanted,
for example, more
insight in your Firebase
database or your cloud
Firestore instance,
that information
is all in Stackdriver.
You just got to go look at it.
But Stackdriver, like anything,
has a barrier to entry.
Right?
And I think one of the
biggest themes of this talk
is that we want to make
things easy on developers.
We want to make them do
as little as possible
in a way that helps us
build more confidently.
And so developers
are already used
to this idea, this system
of how we debug code.
And I would love to
tell you that I believe
the fundamental idea
of debugging code
is like breakpoints and
good tooling, but it's not.
People console.log or printf
the hell out of their code.
It doesn't matter who you
are, it's how we debug stuff.
And that's fine.
Right?
Like, it's great that we
have more advanced tools
in Google Cloud
and in Stackdriver
that do crazy in-production
and breakpoints and stacks
and stuff like that.
But most developers
aren't going to use those.
And they're especially
not going to use them
if they're trying to ship
something by next week.
So let's just make it better.
Right?
Let's not change anything that
the developers are already
doing.
Let's just make the
situation better for them.
So just by console logging
in a Cloud Function,
if you normally go to
the Firebase console
and check it out you
see a fairly simple view
of this information.
But if you head over
to Stackdriver Logging
inside the Cloud console, you
will see a much nicer view
of that same data.
So this is every log.
It actually pulls logs from all
sorts of Google Cloud Services.
It's not just Firebase.
It's not just Cloud Functions.
You can get logs from Kubernetes
or Cloud Run or anything
like that.
But in this case, these
are just console logs
from our functions.
And you can see it's broken
up into a few columns here.
Left column, a
little colored icon
to tell us what
type of log it is.
And after that we have what
time it was happened that.
Next to that we have
the function name
that reported this log.
So we have two functions here,
request cool and fulfill cool.
And then after that we
have a unique invocation
ID that, one-to-one,
whatever-whatever, that's
the id of that invocation.
And then after that we
have whatever printed.
So this is great.
But it's better if
we can filter in.
So if we click on one
of those nice numbers,
it'll automatically write this
little query for us and say,
all right.
Here's the log for the
invocation of that function--
that specific one that
you just clicked on.
And we can see the
entire lifecycle.
And you can see
now, when it's not
in this entirely
big blob of logs,
that we have things like
how long the function took.
We have an idea about what
went through and what happened.
And this is without
changing console log.
This is just still
console logging,
but getting ingested into
stack Stackdriver Logging
automatically.
And this is already there
for your Cloud Functions
you're already using.
You just have to go click on it.
So this is great.
You can write all sorts
of custom queries.
You can do all sorts
of different things
in terms of creating
custom metrics.
If you wanted alerts based on
when certain errors happened,
if you want to just search
for the word "error"
and say anytime that happens
we should alert someone.
You can do that.
But luckily you don't have to,
because we can do even better.
So we want to give
developers the tools
to debug without placing
a burden on them.
And one of those burdens is
not just changing the code,
but the other burden is
actually looking at these logs
and understanding that.
Right?
Like, looking through
this is not trivial.
That takes time.
So why don't we give them
a nice, aggregate view
of that data of those logs?
And let's do it without
any code changes.
Well, that's that
Stackdriver Error Reporting.
So Error Reporting--
again, it's just in there.
You just got to go
click the button,
please use Stackdriver
Error Reporting, and all
your Cloud Functions,
all your Firebase stuff
will get aggregated into these.
See, instead of a big, big log
I have a few instances of errors
that have happened in my code.
And we have a lot
of nice information
here, like how many
times it's happened,
when it was most recently seen.
Of course, if we click into
that, the full stack trace,
we get a histogram of
when it's been happening.
We can link it to
internal bug tracking.
We have all of this.
And most importantly, we have
the ability to set up alerts
when new bugs occur.
So we don't have to ever
look at that log reactively.
We don't have to
go think about it.
We can just say, all right.
If a new error occurs or
an old error happens again,
just shoot me an email.
Hit up pager duty.
Right?
Call the on-call.
Do whatever you
have to do in order
to get this information across
that something is going wrong.
And again, no code changes.
So once we've done that--
all right.
Once we are very aware of
all the new errors happening,
the realization we all have
is that really not everything
bad happening is an error.
Right?
Like, there are
situations you don't
want to get into that aren't
errors but they're not good.
So what do we do?
How do we have that insight?
Well Stackdriver
has another thing.
And this section
of Stackdriver is
where all of these metrics
from all these Google services
get poured into this one place.
And in this case we're looking--
it's very hard to see, but we're
looking at the execution of two
different Cloud Functions.
There's a pink
line on the bottom
and a blue line on the top.
The blue line is
the front-end server
and the pink line
is the one that
actually does the creation
of the content that
gets served up.
So you would expect
in all situations
that that blue line be
bigger than that pink line,
because at most the amount of
requests to create something
can be as big as the amount
of requests to serve it.
So in this case, where that
pink line is super low,
that's exactly what we'd expect.
And we can go in here.
We can look at all
sorts of metrics.
We can look at CPU time and
memory use and aggregate data
over years or days or hours,
we can create dashboards
all from all this
Firebase information.
And it's not just stopped
at Cloud Functions.
Like I said, we have databases.
We have Cloud Storage.
We have the most insight
available to you about Firebase
all thrown into
Stackdriver metrics.
So that's cool.
But again, it's
not the same if we
don't get-- if I have
to look at that thing
and think about it,
that's not as good.
So we can go in and
create custom alerts.
For example, in this situation
I have a Cloud Function
that runs once a day.
It goes and clears some caches,
does some other housekeeping.
I don't really care if
that function doesn't
run on any given day,
but I do want to know
if it's stopped running.
So I set up this alert based on
a custom report in Stackdriver
Logging that says, hey, if this
function hasn't been invoked
in about 48 hours, go ahead.
Hit me up.
Shoot me a message
and let me know
if something's going wrong.
This can tie into
pager duty or any
of the other on-call
services so that you
can know when something--
whatever it is--
is going wrong in your service.
And, of course, because
these situations are nice,
well-understood
alerts and conditions,
if that situation gets
resolved you'll get
told about that, too.
So not only do
you get told, hey,
that function didn't
run for some reason
but you'll get told,
oh, now it did.
Now you're all good.
All right.
Last section.
Shortest section-- pricing.
Pricing calculators
are great, but they're
absolutely useless if
you have no information.
If you've ever sat
down and thought,
man, I want to build this thing.
We're going to do this thing.
How much would it cost to
run 100 users on this server
or 1,000 or 100,000?
That's just about
impossible to tell.
You have no idea how
many megahertz hours
you're going to use.
You probably can't guess
how much RAM you need.
Any of these things are
very, very difficult to tell.
So if only there was a
way some service that gave
us incredibly-detailed
information about our service
so that we could put reasonable
numbers into these calculators.
And we just talked about that.
That's Stackdriver.
All of that information to
do forward-looking analysis
is available in Stackdriver,
and you can plop it
into your calculator.
Second thing, Firebase
now has paid support.
So all of this-- everything
I've talked to you about--
you can get on the phone
now and talk to someone.
If you are already a
GCP paid support member,
we now have experts
staffed there
to talk to you about Firebase,
answer technical questions.
Anything about scaling
Firebase you need to know
is now included in
GCP paid support.
All right.
So what did we cover?
Code, testing, deployment,
rollback, environment,
monitoring, pricing.
That's pretty much what you
need to be thinking about.
I appreciate you all
coming to the talk.
I'll be around for questions.
Thank you for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]